hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I hope you enjoyed your holiday
festivities but now we have to get right
back to talking about video games 2020
is going to be a bumper year for video
games and it all kicks off with
January's offerings here's 5 games worth
your attention over the first month of
2020 and once again I found a
free-to-play game for us all to enjoy
together so if you're ready let's do
this
any Dragon Ball fans in the house on
January 17th you'll be able to get your
hands on Dragon Ball Z Kakarot in this
one you'll be reliving the life of Goku
which means epic battles time and time
again but Kakarot goes beyond fighting
and lets us experience everyday
activities from catching and eating fish
to exploring the world so yeah it's a
role-playing game one of the key selling
points will be very pleasing to Dragon
Ball fans in which never seen before
story moments will have answers to some
of your burning questions when it comes
to Dragon Ball law Kakarot is set up in
a way which will please the hardcore
fans but is also open enough for
newcomers like me to finally understand
what the heck is going on so one day we
will be able to understand the argument
about this word is it pronounced
kamehameha or Kamehameha let me know if
you'd like some gameplay on the channel
Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot releases on January 17th on ps4
Xbox one and PC
[Music]
next on the list is a game which arrived
a year ago Kingdom Hearts 3
well January 23rd sees the DRC expansion
remind release did you know that this
RPG franchise has been going for 18
years thus far with 13 iterations and
remixes pretty damn impressive well on
his way to rescue Kyrie at the end of
the main quest Sora travels to the
Keyblade graveyard to discover the seven
guardians of light the gameplay loop
remains the same with an additional
storyline a new episode 13 bosses to
battle a secret episode to discover a
new slideshow feature and a premium menu
for new gameplay challenges to give
Kingdom Hearts further replayability and
difficulty setting - to push you to
breaking point oh and is also a new
forum for your key blades Oathkeeper and
Oblivion if more Kingdom Hearts 3 is
what you need in your life then grab it
on January 23rd on ps4 one month later
the Xbox one gets it it's another one of
those timed exclusives sorry about the
Xbox tab so if you're here for the free
game this month let's cover it now back
when the battle royale boom took over
the entire gaming world many developers
try to take the game genre in different
directions over the past year the Darwyn
project has been in test status on PC
and Xbox well get this in January the
game goes into full release on ps4 Xbox
one and PC so let's break it down this
version of battle royale is the closest
to the Hunger Games you can imagine 10
players armed with a bow and axe fight
to the death
while attempting to stay alive in the
environment crafting staying warm by
fires and those sorts of RPG elements
are in abundance here so why only 10
players well in most battle royale games
the early parts are quite boring because
we're all collecting loot and materials
then the game springs into life and
becomes interesting in the final circles
well in the Darwin project you are
always in a top 10 scenario I don't want
to dwell too much on these points right
now because I have a dedicated video
coming in a few weeks but here's the
best and worst part
proximity chat you can hear your
opponents and talk to them this is great
for trash-talking but it's
some terrible thought trash-talking I
honestly can't wait to make a video
about this just like The Hunger Games
the zone shrinks over time and forces
players to fight one another and wait
there's one more important unique
element an 11th player their job is to
run the show they are the director once
again just like The Hunger Games they
can help you they can hinder they can
pass across abilities one of them is
called telepathy which lets the player
talk to the entire group the entire
lobby to prepare for more trash talking
or in my scenario I'll be shouting out
all my social details discord gg fold /
grenade
you should join you should totally join
the Darwin project devs are on winter
break at the moment so I couldn't get a
specific release date other than January
as a whole but rest assured I'll give
you more info as soon as I know it as a
random stab in the dark I'll say it will
release on January the 23rd that is a
real random guess
so now most people have clicked off this
video because the free game has been and
gone so let's crack on I got to admit
January is a pretty weak month how about
a tennis simulator a old tennis - is the
official tie-in for the Australian Open
which also happens in January did you
know each year
visually all the licenses are here
training gear manufacturers advertising
on every single wall it's it's like the
real event if you played the original
the real improvement is the mole capping
of each player meaning every single
player swings the racket as they would
do in real life no generic strokes here
realism is the way to go
in a old tennis tennis video games have
quite a niche audience but hopefully
this was useful to someone äô tennis -
drops on january 9th on ps4 Xbox one and
PC Oh on twitch - and finally have a
look at this journey to the savage
planet this is described as an upbeat
co-op adventure in which you will
encounter weird and wonderful creatures
like a farting bird it's true as an
employee of kindred aerospace which is
the fourth best interstellar exploration
company by the way you are tasked with
traveling the galaxy and finding new
places the game retails at half the
price of a typical game making this much
more affordable
after the pounding your wallet took of a
Christmas if I had to describe it I say
it has many similarities to normal sky
but after 20 hours in that game it
became extremely somber and quite
depressing so I can see why this game is
trying to push up beat as a prominent
part of their advertising
there are also gunplay mechanics here
enemies to fight and platforming
elements - but everything remains
light-hearted throughout if this is your
jam pick up journey to the savage planet
on January 28 on ps4 Xbox one and PC via
the epic star
[Music]
so there we have it five new games that
release in January do any flow to your
boat I got to admit I am looking forward
to the Darwin project I really am I'm
Adam from Playstation grenades all the
best for 2020 make this your year I'll
see you soon
[Music]